voilà donc pour les images de cette
détermination impressionnante des
ukrainiens armelle on va reparler avec
vous de la situation à à kiev et de
cette colonne de chars elle semble
rencontrer quelques soucis sur le chemin
la résistance mais pas que oui alors
elle a été vue étant à l'arrêt donc est
ce qu'il y avait eu changement de
tactique qui avait été demandé par
moscou est ce que c'est un manque de
carburant de ravitaillement c'est à dire
dans ces cas là que la logistique ne
suis pas sur ce genre d'opération la
logistique a toujours été envisagée
quand même un char consomme énormément
donc se poser la question de west qui va
récupérer delà du gazole est quand même
une donnée h à dire assez élémentaire
mais ça veut peut-être dire que dans ces
cas-là on imaginer que le ravitaillement
pourraient se faire surface assez
facilement on a pas d'image vraiment
mise à part cette colonne de ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de l'ukraine je vous
rappelle que le pays est très grand il
est quand même un peu plus grand que la
france on a des grandes plaines à
l'intérieur du
pays c'est les grandes plaines fertiles
qui permettait de faire une politique à
l'école qui en faisait le grenier de la
russie le grenier de l'europe est en
revanche on s'est davantage ce qui se
passe effectivement du côté de l'ouest
du côté de kiev on a vu cette résistance
hors pair des ukrainiens on a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de témoignages de
personnes qui mettent leur famille à
l'abri à l'extérieur des frontières
ukrainienne et qui reviennent combattre
de jeunes de plus anciens et on le voit
effectivement dans le reportage cette
volonté aujourd'hui ils ont été armés
ils ont eu un peu les piscines qui leur
ont été données par les américains ils
ont des mines déjà blinky sont des
missiles antichars justement pour ses
chars pour ses blindés qui peuvent
arriver ils ont aussi des missiles
stinger qui sont les missiles qui tire
normalement sur les avions mais à côté
ça forcément il faut être habilité alors
et lydia quand même une connaissance du
combat depuis 2014 on voit qu'il ya
quand même des milices il ya quand même
un savoir faire mais qui a fait était
une ville à l'occidentale j'allais dire
on était quand même pas dans le donbass
est ce qu'on peut se diriger vers un
scénario catastrophe qui serait l'un des
scénarios catastrophe je précise le
scénario d'un siège long sur kiev avec
une résistance organisée ukrainienne à
l'intérieur de la ville avec des snipers
des armes improvisées est-ce que ce
scénario là se profile aujourd'hui
armelle alors les experts
oui parle de cela j'ai presque du mal a
voulu dire florent tellement
effectivement c'est dur d'admettre que
on peut aller vers une guerre qui va
durer plusieurs mois plusieurs années et
si on est juste dans un raisonnement de
rapport de force oui bien évidemment on
peut aller dans un pourrissement de la
situation parce que deux cent mille
soldats russes quand on compare à 43
millions d'habitants ukrainien on se dit
que le rapport de force et pas forcément
en faveur de vladimir poutine c'est pour
ça qu'il ya des sanctions qui arrivent
de l'extérieur pour aller effectivement
faire essayer d'appuyer poutine mais ce
qui est frappant c'est qu'il n'a pas
encore coupé ni le gaz ni le pétrole aux
européens parce qu'en même temps nous on
est quand même heureux d'avoir ce gaz
est ce pétrole est lui récupère de
l'argent puisque on l'achète en grande
quantité en seulement 40 % de la
consommation européenne on le rappelle
oui oui donc du coup mais en fait ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui montrent
effectivement qu'on peut aller sur une
allée dire une vraie oui un conflit qui
du coup a complètement s'embourber merci
beaucoup armelle pour votre décryptage